le parti libéral du québec s'est
récemment donné comme objectif d'avoir
40 % de candidatures féminines à
l'élection de 2018
est-ce qu'on est d'accord pour s'engager
le cétacé comme objectif pour permettre
aux femmes de briser le plafond de verre
en politique dans l'objectif de la
parité c'est ce qu'on me demande que ce
soit sous forme de lois au rythme on
laisse aller les choses ça peut prendre
encore 5 ans chaque parti aurait à
trouver 60 trois femmes seulement
je pose la question est ce que les
femmes sont intéressés par la politique
autant content si que les boys club
ouvre les portes qu'il faut pour les
femmes c'est tout bête mais ça veut pas
dire parce que la joute est pas adapté
que les femmes ne s'intéressent pas aux
dans la politique faisait des les règles
d ont été écrites par des hommes alors
il faut nous comme femme le réécrire un
oeil pour oeil dent pour dent et autant
les citoyens ne veulent plus autant les
femmes que l'on ne s'engage en politique
reprenne goût que la politique se fasse
vers les façon de faire actuelle c'est à
caillé
trop longtemps installé la london school
of economics a réalisé en 2014 une étude
sur plusieurs élections municipales en
suède où il y avait des quotas hommes
femmes à respecter le constat les quotas
ont relevé la compétence de la classe
politique particulièrement celle des
hommes
là où la représentation des femmes a le
plus augmenté
quand est-ce qu'on le questionnait la
compétence des hommes il s'agit qu'on
parle de places réservées aux femmes
pour tout de suite mettre en cause leurs
compétences
je trouve que c'est un double standard
qui discrimine
[Musique]